economía en france 24 daniel hablando
conmigo en el estudio daniela buena
noche bienvenida los banqueros de eeuu
se rinden cuentas al capitolio hola raúl
muy buenas noches pues el congreso
inició este miércoles una audiencia de
dos días para analizar qué tan útil ha
sido wall street' durante la pandemia a
esta industria recordemos se le culpó de
la gran recesión de hace más de una
década ahora las críticas vinieron por
el lado de que los préstamos a las
empresas se han reducido mientras las
entidades financieras disparan sus
ganancias como vemos por ejemplo raúl en
el primer trimestre las ganancias de
jaypee morgan se multiplicaron por
cuatro las del bank of america se
duplicaron y las de citigroup se
triplicaron frente a hace un año aquí
una de las preguntas del debate con su
respectiva respuesta al aula
como llegamos aquí donde los directores
ejecutivos están ganando 900 veces lo
que ganan algunos de sus trabajadores
estamos muy orgullosos de la oportunidad
que le damos a toda nuestra gente con
nuestro salario inicial es de
aproximadamente 35 mil dólares más
beneficios médicos y de jubilación
cuidamos muy bien a nuestra gente en
términos de capacitación mi compensación
la fija la junta ellos miren múltiples
factores
daniela cambiamos información porque
sirio tú no eras presidencial es marcada
por la crisis económica claro raúl pues
una de las agencias de naciones unidas
se estima que más de 10 años de guerra
le han costado a siria casi 500 mil
millones de dólares de hecho a finales
de 2018 se creía que este país había
perdido más de la mitad del producto
interno bruto que tenía antes del
conflicto ahora veamos la crítica
situación que se ha agudizado con la
pandemia ha hecho que en el último año
la libra haya perdido tres cuartas
partes de su valor y que el costo de los
alimentos y artículos esenciales se haya
triplicado según el banco mundial
hoy en día raúl 13 millones de sirios
requieren ayuda humanitaria y 9 de cada
10 son incapaces de poner comida sobre
la mesa y satisfacer sus necesidades
básicas tales daniela cambiamos
información ahora dos grandes petroleras
del mundo en la lupa por sus prácticas
ambientales hablemos primero de
exxonmobil cuyos accionistas votaron a
favor de reemplazar al menos a dos de
los 12 miembros de su junta directiva
sala petrolera más grande de eeuu eso
fue producto de una especie de rebelión
impulsada por un pequeño grupo de
accionistas que consideran que los
actuales miembros de los no hacen lo
suficiente en la transición hacia
energías limpias
ahora vamos a otro lado la presión a
esta industria para abordar la crisis
climática está creciendo con el pasar de
los días y justo hoy un tribunal de
países bajos ordenó a shell que es una
de las petroleras más grandes del mundo
que reduzca sus emisiones de dióxido de
carbono en un 45% hasta 2030 en un fallo
sin precedentes escuchemos
este es un día histórico por primera vez
en la historia un hueso ordenó a un gran
contaminante reducir sus co2 y su
contribución al peligroso cambio
climático
por primera vez tengo la experiencia de
que logremos abordar el cambio climático
un avance para tener esta tragedia de
cambio climático daniela se firmaron las
acciones de la principal aluminio
aerolínea de américa latina'
estamos hablando de latam airlines cuyas
acciones se desplomaron en más del 20
por ciento este miércoles en la bolsa de
santiago que tuvo que suspender su
cotización
esto ocurre justo un año después de su
declaración de bancarrota y en medio de
rumores sobre la posible venta de sus
activos en brasil a la aerolínea azul
cuyas acciones sí subieron casi 10 por
ciento la empresa negó la información
pero el mercado tiene la sospecha porque
precisamente esta semana la tama anunció
que puso fin a un acuerdo de códigos
compartidos con azul que mantenían desde
el año pasado ahora indicadores daniela
la bolsa de nueva york que el
seropositivo en medio de la
comparecencia de sus líderes en el
congreso
bolsas europeas terminaron planas
después de que el banco central se
comprometiera a que la política
monetaria seguirá siendo flexible para
poder superar la crisis y las bolsas
latinoamericanas tuvieron ganancias en
brasil impulsadas por el sector aéreo
para finalizar que nuestra como si fuera
el día raúl 8 mil 450 millones de
dólares eso pagar a amazon por envíeme
el estudio de cine y televisión detrás
de éxitos como james bond o shark tank
esta es la segunda adquisición más
grande de la empresa después de whole
foods y la introduce en hollywood para
competir con otras grandes industrias
como de disney más o netflix así era
como siempre muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información económica a
ustedes también gracias continúa con
nosotros y muy buena noche
[Música]